In this problem, an engineer in a lab wants to find the dry unit weight of a soil sample
in pounds per cubic feet, within a 0.025 cubic foot mold.
The following information are available.
The total weight of the soil sample in mold is 8.5 pounds.
The water content of the soil sample is 10%.
The weight of the mold is 4.4 pounds.
And the answer is most likely one of the following.
So the first thing we can do in this problem is search for dry unit weight in the reference
manual.
This can lead you, I think the third occurrence will take you to the geotechnical chapter,
chapter 3, to section 3.8.3 weight volume relationships.
So the first thing we need to, we can find here looking at this page is that the problem
is asking us to find the dry unit weight of a soil sample.
The equation provided for dry unit weight on that page is gamma d equals gamma total over 1 plus
w.
So in order to solve this problem for gamma d, we first need to find gamma total.
So our second step here is going to be to find the weight of the soil sample only.
Which will be our gamma total.
So we have the weight of the sample in mold and weight of the mold.
So to get the weight of the soil by itself, we simply need to subtract the two.
So 8.5 pounds minus 4.4 pounds will give us 4.1 pounds.
And that is the weight of the soil sample by itself.
That will enable us to find gamma total, which is going to be the weight of the whole sample
divided by the size of the mold.
So that is going to be gamma equals w over v, which is going to be the weight of the
solids plus the weight of the water over the volume of solids plus the volume of water plus
the volume of air.
There is no specific equation in the manual that is written out like this in this chapter,
but if you look at the image provided on page 139 of the reference manual showing the weight
volume relationships, you can see that this is what the total gamma consists of.
So our total gamma has been calculated out to 4.1 pounds.
And the provided total volume is given up here as 0.025 cubic feet.
So this is going to give us 164 pounds per cubic foot.
From here, we can use the equation for the dry unit weight that we found in the reference
manual here to find gamma d.
So gamma d is going to be gamma total, which we've calculated out to be 164 pounds
per cubic feet.
And 1 plus, in this case, w is going to equal 10% as provided.
This is the same thing as writing 10 over 100 or 0.1, which is the way we will describe
it in this case.
And then finally, gamma d is calculated out to be 149.09 pounds per cubic foot.
Our closest answer is going to be answer A.
And that's all it takes to solve this problem.